we need to make sure that our law
enforcement authorities have access to
data which is necessary for the
Prevention of terrorist acts and serious
transnational crimes nan de serranos
sustained no success on my surah
al-fatah no la liberté a la conquista in
renewable a delusional repair no chick
mi amo union europaea
potassium of on dotty su la libertad
Europol says there are over 3000 EU
foreign fighters radicalized
military-trained returning to the EU and
exploiting the gaps and deficiencies in
law enforcement information exchange
across the EU this directive would help
to address that in all major terrorist
attacks mr. Kirk hope over the past 10
years the perpetrators were known by the
services of the different countries and
the problem is today not so much that we
don't collect the info the problem is
that we don't share the info it is
essential that my strengths and economic
growth and reduce unemployment in the yo
the elo the internet scenario bad
organization but how it did it sound if
dr. Stockton invested zones invested
zones for ebert spy commands million and
no jobs in the operation on my own in
stay in Cannon and receivership video
rotation Y on that other have added fun
expand we are in fact very worried that
member states so far I'm not making
capital pledges for the fund I think
that way more is a Adama Tirupathi Nino
halted missed
ambi theoreticaly marvel at every inhale
the we're up 30% reduce it again
Twitter's and dirty I think that knee
monk better do it on dot and into circle
agus in India and ok Sheena the way he
desired lungs on our toe that is what
ready Toto optimism rating Perez Canada
and Australia daren't take a turn with
the lay the political isolation or see
energy efficiency mood do top priorities
and vernacular plan to be
a kilo of anak hope that da da da Croft
that le belong education also violent
water getting the very top to name over
the prevailing
the lake is dead hail innovative or
plotting it too super